why we come here time travel we were on
a mission I wanted to go home to see the
people that I loved I was trying to
avenge my fallen comrades
I wanted to relaunch a fast casual
restaurant chain with slightly better
food and local bands on the weekends I
get it there's no mission this is about
survival that's something we are pretty
good at another escape on your watch
saying Jackalope as long as they are
loose I'm gonna be the one to bring them
in we need us to grow we're and win we
are know if you'll excuse me
daddy's going dancing where this is a
kill mission they're fugitives body
spray what if we become the best
versions of ourselves totally last jump
for old times sake got their game face
off I'm gonna hurt you Gandhi hey I'm
gonna hurt you real bad
I just want to go home our Savior back
from with it this is bad
do my eyes deceive me can we break time
you got a live feed in here are they
using any close-ups because I feel like
they're shooting everything in a wide
and well the dramas right here
[Music]